let's talk about the BBC I'm sure you're
ready to discuss that in more detail the
director General told us I told us I
should say the internal investigation
has been paused
is the government content with that
well we're very conscious that the
police have asked the BBC to pause their
investigations and it's quite proper
that the BBC do so under those
circumstances and so we're now just
going to have to see what happens with
the police investigation and the
outcomes of that the police have already
said the Met have already said they're
not investigating a criminal offense at
this time they're now scoping afternoon
allegations
um the police have said they're not
investigating
well as we know there have been two more
sets of allegations that have come to
light as I say if the police have asked
the BBC to pause their investigation
then the BBC must do that and as a
government Minister I will not must not
speculate as to what the police may or
may not be doing okay well let me put it
this way then what's the government
going to do to make sure that this is
not kicked into the long grass
uh well the it's for the BBC to
investigate their own matters but of
course if the police are involved if
they're scoping then it will be for the
police to apply the law as as it stands
and to see whether there is a case or
not but it might the government must not
interfere in any police investigation
that that is very very states have said
they're not investigating well no they
have said that they are scoping and we
have to respect that they specifically
said they're not investigated yeah but
as I say there are two more allegations
this is a very fast moving situation and
it would not be right for a government
minister to comment on police
operational activity you know I'm a
former home office Minister Kay you know
I cannot comment on such things I'm not
asking you to comment I'm asking you how
you're going to make sure that it's not
kicked into the long grass well as I say
it's for the BBC to conduct its
investigations the police I mean we know
that it took seven weeks the police is
escoping this and it is a fast-moving
situation
more people have made apparently made
sets or there are sets of allegations or
actually all together
um well then it shows again how
fast-moving it is doesn't it it
certainly does but it also shows that
the BBC have not learned their lessons
from Jimmy Savile Rolf Harris and the
like
um this male presenter was accused of
engaging in soliciting sexually explicit
images whether they were illegal or not
the police as you said are looking into
that surely they have completely failed
to learn the lessons of the past
well I there will come a point for
postmortems on this and the director
general of the BBC
um obviously gave an interview yesterday
there will come a point for a postman he
won't he won't stand to scrutiny from
others I mean that that again
um is is a matter for him but it this we
we have to let these processes go
through because appalling that they
haven't learned the lessons of the past
because the allegations are so serious
uh and yeah we have always acknowledged
this we have to let these processes now
go through I mean there will certainly
be lessons to be learned for the BBC and
I can understand why people may be
asking questions at this point and I'm
sure those questions will continue to be
asked what would you like to say to this
uh boys
um this person's parents today
they contacted the BBC they did nothing
about it for seven weeks they may they
sent an email and the call didn't go
through and then it was only when a
national newspaper held their feet to
the fire to their start to Scuttle
around
again that is for the BBC to justify the
good minister to the parents this
morning are you just going to Stonewall
it I I I'm a government Minister I
cannot give personal views on this but
what I can say is that you know my
history as a home office Minister has
been about helping victims of sexual and
domestic abuse it's one of the reasons
I'm on today to talk about some of the
work we're trying to do
and what is important if you don't mind
do you agree with you mine the BBC
presenter should be named well okay what
is important is that as I've said all
along in this I was out on the media
round on Sunday we have to remember that
there is a young person it seems now
there are more young people at the heart
of this and in all of our conversations
we have to bear that in mind because
whatever the whatever comes out of these
investigations this will be a very very
difficult time for the people at the
heart yeah and I'm asking you to give a
word to the parents but you've chosen
not to do that that's not fair very fair
what I've said is that it is incredibly
difficult it will will be incredibly
difficult for the people at the center
of this and we have to be mindful of
that in all of our conversations and you
know the the reason I have I cannot talk
about the processes but of course any
parent looking at the reading the
newspapers will feel
um enormous sympathy for parents who are
facing the sorts of issues that have
been raised in the papers okay you can
comment on whether or not this presenter
should name himself his colleague Jeremy
Vine says he should
well again uh it's I mean the the issue
that has come to light with this and
indeed
um as we see more the power of social
media
um in nowadays that there is this real
problem that I think we as a society
have to face as to the impact on
innocent people when allegations of this
sort are made and people try to work out
who is at the center oh we can fix that
by him naming himself well again it will
be
um I'm not going to
um comment on an individual and the
duties or responsibilities of them to
name themselves what we do have to do is
just try and give these process a bit of
space to be able to come into process to
the ministry you well know that um it's
his colleagues are finding themselves in
the spotlight because he won't name
himself and one of his colleagues has
said come on now Now's the Time Yeah and
and so I think there's a real um as I
say an issue here as to what happens
with these sorts of cases when they
rightly attract so much media and public
attention the impact that that has on
people who are nothing to do with the
allegations and I do think there's a
role here for social media companies to
see what they are doing and checking on
their platforms and of course we're
trying through the Online safety Bill to
bring some of those standards into law
to ensure that not just in this respect
but across the board the social media
companies are held to it your boss says
he's shocked by what's going on your
tips are in through the raindrops this
morning over it should MPS use
parliamentary privilege to name the
presenter
uh again every single parliamentarian
will be very careful about using that
privilege
um and it will be for the speaker to
decide whether if such a a name if a
name is provided that as to whether or
not that is in order I mean it is for
individual parliamentarians to decide
that but one of your colleagues sat
there yesterday and said that that they
he would urge uh his colleagues not to
I'm asking you whether you think they
should or not uh I I think we all have a
responsibility actually with
parliamentary privileges and of course
again I'm afraid I do take a longer View
and the reason I'm being so careful okay
is because I when I used to prosecute
trials I had abusive process
applications put in certain cases where
media attention was such that the
defendant claimed that he was he could
not receive a fair trial so this is why
I'm being extremely careful of my
answers to you today okay I talk to me
parliamentary privilege it is very very
difficult and parliamentarians really do
have to remember it huge responsibility
they face talk to me about economic
abuse and what you want to say about
that this morning so we think around one
in six women suffer from economic abuse
and that can be anything from a
perpetrator taking away your your wages
or your benefits to taking a loan out in
your name without your knowledge or
locking food cupboards at home in the
kitchen and so what we're trying to do
is to help improve understanding of
economic abuse following our Domestic
Abuse Act a couple of years ago and the
practical ways that we can all help
people who are facing that sort of abuse
I am the minister responsible for the
UK's tax system and I we have an agency
called hmrc who collects the taxes
I I don't we have so many acronyms in
the treasury I I never like to assume
but
um we're rolling out guidance to 30 000
hmrc staff today on economic abuse and
what they can do to help when members of
the public ring our helplines and ask
for help or are in distress but what
we're trying to do as well over the
summer with the help of domestic abuse
Charities is to create a digital program
that we will be able to publish freely
for every single business around the
country to use if they have customer
service helplines and they think people
might be contacting them in distress and
how they can best help people who are
suffering from economic abuse so it's a
really I hope really a good story of
ambition on this okay Saturday